Nicole is with us a NAPA hi Nicole how
are you hi mr. Lampe how are you better
than I deserve how can I help
well I am just starting baby step two
and I am going in gazelle speed as you
would say and the Total Money Makeover
but my husband isn't I manage all of the
money for our family we have our bank
account set up together and we are just
completely at odds on his outside
spinning we have a budget set you have
everything and stone on spreadsheets and
we're just not clicking and on the same
page as relates to his outside spending
yeah that's correcting more like his
mother than his wife yeah and he's
probably tired of that so were you yes I
am we're in separate beds right now
since Sunday I just had a breakdown and
completely crying and over it because
I'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired
how long have you guys how long have you
guys been married we have been married
for 21 years you
what's your household income we are at a
hundred and sixty three thousand well
you've hit the wall that is very
predictable okay and sometimes it takes
people longer than others and it can
happen to men or woman where the other
spouse is not involved at all and is on
an allowance he gets tired of being
treated like a child and you get tired
of being the only adult right and and it
create crashes inevitably it crashes and
so I would tell you this I mean I don't
know what you guys can do you may need
to sit down with a pastor a good
marriage counselor for sure to get to
get moving on the right page but it
could sound something like this
okay honey I've been completely wrong
and you've been completely wrong we've
got to restart this whole thing
I don't want to be your mother anymore I
need you to be a man and you don't want
to me to be a nag and you want to have a
vote in these finances and so we got to
start again you now are in charge of the
budget with me as two adults we are
going to look into the future and to
determine where we want to go and where
we want to go is not spending like we're
in Congress where we want to go is not
being an immature child me or you where
we want to go is we're gonna look in the
future like two adults and say we've got
to clean up this debt and we've got to
retire with dignity and we've got to
enjoy our life to some degree while
we're doing all of that you get a vote
and I get a vote but we're gonna have
mature goals and we're gonna work
together I am no longer going to do a
budget and try to tell you what you're
going to do you're gonna be a man and
you're gonna work beside me the two of
us are gonna work together and we're
gonna come up with a game plan together
we both have a vote that's gonna be a
little uncomfortable for you because
you've been used to being in control and
you're a bit of a control freak
I am and he's gonna be uncomfortable for
him because he's kind of used to being
lazy about this subject he's had no
involvement in city/21 freaking years
yeah and it's overdue he's gonna have to
man up and come to the table now does he
have to become a spreadsheet nerd like
miss Nicole no but we're gonna make the
decisions on the money together and so
the way it sounds is the nerd of the
family you in my family it's me lays out
a budget and then both of us look at it
together and together we are going to
approve a plan that is good for our
future it's not me telling Sharon what
to do it's not you telling your husband
what to do and he has a vote and he's
gonna mess with your little plan you may
lose a few battles with your gizelle
intensity and you need to turn your
gizelle intensity off right now
until you get him on board him being on
board and the two of you working
together is more important
than density to your success yeah right
Dave well thank you so much and thank
you for coming into our home I thank God
for you every day well I'm proud of you
and you guys can do this and if you want
to get him on the phone and call back
we'll talk to both of you because I
appreciate it there's a new light
there's enough blame to go around here
and either one of your bad people but
you've been doing this the wrong way so
long that it blew up in your face and
the wrong way is is that he did the
wrong ways he didn't have a vote and you
got tired of being the only one carrying
all the responsibility I totally yeah
and and today's it's over I ain't your
mama yep
ain't your mama that's it